Okay.
Here's the painful truth.
Most dreams never come true and it isn't
because people aren't working hard.
It's not because they're not
worthy or they're not good.
It's the simple reality that the things
that you're dreaming about are hard as
hell to accomplish.
So if you want to accomplish them,
let me tell you one thing right now,
you cannot ever be
passive and most people,
that's the posture that
they're in all the time.
People are going to tell you
terrible advice like be patient,
but the reality is you can't be patient,
not if you want to achieve at the highest
level. And if patients is your thing,
if you want to chill, if you want
to relax, that is absolutely fine.
There's no moral obligation to aim high.
There's no moral obligation to want to
be one of the greatest in the world.
But let me tell you right now,
if you want to be one of
the greatest of all time,
the reality is you're
fighting an uphill battle.
The reality is your going to have to
go so hard to make that a reality that
other people simply cannot imagine working
that hard for anything in their life.
That's the simple truth
and once you realize that,
once you realize that the people
that achieve at the highest level,
they have one thing in common,
they will bury them. It would work.
They'd put so much energy into
what they're trying to accomplish,
that other people simply
fall by the wayside.
People simply can't imagine
trying to keep up with that,
and so what they say is
that person's extraordinary.
What they say is that person
is naturally talented.
What they tell themselves is that person,
that's something that they don't have
because what they don't want to do is face
the hard truth that the dreams that they
have aren't coming true simply because
they're not making the right decisions.
They're not pushing themselves to learn.
Once you embrace that, you're hopelessly
average. That's where we all start.
That's the beauty of it.
The greatest piece of news that I can
give you is that you are hopelessly
average. That was where you started, but
it doesn't have to be where you stay.
You can become anything you want to be,
but how to put in that inhuman
amount of work to improve.
But if you focus on that,
if you focus on improving,
then then your dreams
really can become a reality.
But it has to be this aggressive posture.
It has to be waking up every day and
asking yourself one simple question,
how do I get better today
than I was yesterday?
If you are myopically focused on that,
if that is the driving thing in your life
that you don't worry about whether or
not you're good or great or talented,
you just worry about,
am I getting better today
than I was yesterday?
Am I putting in that kind of energy?
Am I working hard enough to get better?
Am I working hard enough
to outperform other people?
Am I willing to hold myself to
this incredibly high standard?
If you're willing to do that and be
real with yourself about whether or not
you're making progress,
then then your dreams really can come
true and that's what I want for people.
I want people to know that.
I want people to believe it
to the core of their being.
You can do anything you set your mind to,
and if you need encouragement, let this
be that encouragement. You can do it.
I don't care how average
you are in the beginning,
who do you want to become and what price
are you willing to pay to get there?
And when the answer to that question is,
I want to be the best and I'm willing
to pay an extraordinary price to get
there,
then and only then you will get there.
Yeah.